après les fêtes de trappes et de la
verrière place maintenant à la fête des
quartiers à guyancourt qui va se
dérouler ce samedi et pour en parler sur
ce plateau thomas sûrs d'y responsable
du service jeunesse et de l'animation
des quartiers de la ville bonjour à vous
bonjour alors si vous vous êtes là
évidemment c'est pour parler c'est de
cette belle fête des quartiers qui va se
passer du côté de lui en cours
l'objectif de l'événement qu'elle est il
alors c'est un événement un fait qui
vient ponctuer une année riche en
événements en fait à guyancourt on a
l'habitude d'avoir des événements qui
rythment comme ça vous par exemple à la
rentrée on a souvent fait alors
quartiers en fête c'est une fête auquel
tiennent beaucoup beaucoup les vivants
courtois le principe est simple c'est un
événement qui fédère l'ensemble du
public sur des animations très très
large sur l'ensemble de la ville et donc
sur une journée donc c'est très très
festif effectivement alors ça va se
parle ça va se passer dans quatre
quartiers principalement une fête des
quartiers on pourrait se dire avec la
société qu'on connaît très
individualiste maintenant ça sert à
créer les liens justement alors
effectivement avions court on a la
chance d'avoir en fait un tissu
associatif très très dense et aussi un
public au sein des quartiers qui très
rapidement en fait sont mis on va dire
sont associés à la réflexion de
l'animation des des structures donc on a
ce qu'on appelle lé comité d'animation
par exemple qui est composé en fait
d'habitants d'associations et donc ils
vont donner leur avis très rapidement
définir en fait les thèmes par maison de
quartier par exemple pour la fête des
quartiers et puis décider ensemble de
lancement des animations ça vote à main
levée ça discute voilà mais c'est pas
tous certes effectivement au delà des
côtes et d'animation on a aussi un
ensemble de partenaires d'associations
voilà deux ça va aussi vers le club de
prévention spécialisée passerelle 78 un
ensemble d'associations qui sont très
parties prenantes et ensemble on décide
de réfléchir à un an de aux activités
qui vont faire ce jour là mais il ya
aussi les écoles je peux citer les
écoles les crèches les médiathèques le
collège aussi voilà un ensemble
d'acteurs effective l'objectif au final
c'est que tout le monde y participe pour
éviter que chacun regarde devant sa
porte en fait toute l'année c'est un peu
ça on reste cloisonné effectivement on
s'offre un petit peu sur ce tissu dense
un saut corps social qui est vraiment
vivant sur la ville de guyancourt l'idée
c'est vraiment de sortir de
l'individualisme
de connaître de partager c'est un moment
convivial fédérateur dans le jargon on
dit que c'est une démocratie
participative effectivement les met en
lien rapidement dans la réflexion et
petit à petit en fait ces groupes
constitués vont réfléchir ensemble se
connaître et donc il ya déjà un lien qui
est fait en amont six mois avant
l'événement et le jour j même au delà un
sermon la même un repas partagé avant
l'événement de façon à consolider un
petit peu voilà ces différents habitants
qui se connaissent peu ou des fois bien
et petit à petit vont se consolider en
7,7 connaissance comme vous le disiez ce
sont les habitants eux mêmes qui ont
choisi les thématiques de cette année il
y en a quatre importantes quelles sont
elles alors on a donc quatre maisons de
quartier on à théodore monod par exemple
qui a décidé de travailler sur le
l'espace en fait le but que son thème
habituel c'est la science là c'est la
conquête de l'espace alors effectivement
c'est ça va être donc décliné mais voilà
on a aussi les festivités médiévales
pour ce qui est de renoir une maison de
quartier aussi qui est très vivante ça
attire toujours beaucoup
oui je pense que ça fascine aussi c'est
pas pour rien que le thème a été retenu
effectivement et puis on a la magie
notamment aussi qui va être traitée sur
le pont du rock thouars et bien sûr le
volume thème qui a été retenu pour les
garennes tous ces thèmes on pourrait
croire que c'est plus pour enfants c'est
quand même tout comique cette fête des
quartiers le principe effectivement de 7
cette journée de festivités est
intergénérationnel serre que tout bon
s'y retrouve ça va de la petite enfance
ou des stands d'animation de maquillage
par exemple seront
seront offerts au public bien sûr pour
les jeunes les jeunes sont partis
prenants il s'est fait par et pour les
jeunes ont la d notamment parce qu'elle
soit 118 qui participera à l'est des
matchs de foot on aura aussi des
ateliers de graff et puis on va jusqu à
tous les publics effectivement des
animations dans la journée notamment les
déambulations du théâtre de la danse
c'est très riche très variés
effectivement autant dire qu'il y en
aura pour tous les goûts samedi donc
rendez vous entre 10h30 grosso modo et
19 heures pour les pour les horaires les
plus tardifs ce samedi un peu partout
dans guyancourt oui et puis je pense que
on peut pas le rater ça saute aux yeux
et on compte sur vous merci beaucoup en
tout cas thomas d'être venu au rendez
vous ce samedi pour cette fête des
quartiers merci